Sparks flew yesterday at the world
economic Forum as the environmentalist
globalists started attacking the
globalist environmentalists after Greta
tunberg arrived in Davos
we are right now in Davos where the
basically the people who are mostly
fueling the destruction of the planets
the people who are at the very core of
the climate crisis the people who are
investing in fossil fuels etc etc and
and yet somehow these are the people
that we seem to rely on solving our
problems where they have proven time and
time again that they are not
prioritizing that they are prioritizing
self self greed corporate greed
um and short-term economic profits above
people and above planets and we are
listening we seem to be listening to
them rather than the people who are
actually affected by the the climate
crisis the people who are living on the
front lines and
and that's that kind of tells us the
situation how absurd this is
the whole episode resembled the
iran-iraq war in that normal people wish
that both sides could lose but even more
than that the fight resembled a stage
play the liberal Elites wunderkind
showing up to the fancy party in
Switzerland to tell them all how very
naughty they've been all to the fawning
praise and Applause of the elites who
lapped up the performative abuse a
tawdry Affair and a play acted fight for
the cameras while behind closed doors
the globalist agenda moved forward full
steam ahead I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael nols Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Big G who says
if John Kerry couldn't get his friends
off a remote island back when he was
Thurston Howell III how is he supposed
to save the world that's so true John If
You're Gonna Save the World how about
you get off that Island huh love you you
can't even keep your marriage in check
John
lovey bring me another coconut please
I'm saving the planet lovey when you
want to
talk to all of your friends you don't
need to fly to a fancy Alpine town in
Switzerland you can just pick up pure
talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles if
you are planning this year to do
business with companies that share what
you believe in you got to check out Pure
Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it is proudly
veteran-owned employees at us-based
customer service team and absolutely
refuses to spend money on fake news
networks not to mention Pure Talk
service is fantastic one of the largest
networks in the country you can get
blazing fast data talk and text for as
low as thirty dollars a month that's
probably half of what you're paying
Verizon ATT and T-Mobile switch over to
Pure Talk it takes just 10 minutes while
keeping your phone and your phone number
your first month is guaranteed risk-free
try it if you're not totally happy with
the service you get your money back
there's nothing to lose here except
those High bills this year make it a
goal to support the companies that
support you go to puretalk.com into
promo code Knowles to save 50 off your
first month puretalk.com promo code
Knowles Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
amid all of the silly little play for
the cameras things that happened at the
world economic Forum like the Greta
tunberg performances and all the rest of
it
there were some scary stuff that went
down the European commission vice
president made a claim that should put a
little bit of fear in every single
American this European commission BP
said that the United States soon will
follow Western Europe in Banning
hate speech we need the people who
understand the language and the case law
in the country because what qualifies as
HP as illegal hate speech which you will
have soon also in the U.S I think that
we we have a strong reason why we have
this in the criminal law uh we we need
the platforms to Simply work with Mr
language and to identify such cases the
AI would be too dangerous
yes you will soon have it there in the
United States because we will make sure
that you have it there because we are
going to take this rare but narrow
opportunity to reset the world
that was the subtext of what she was
saying most conservatives are listening
to that and saying no you won't
dagnabbit we're gonna stand firm on our
first amendment you're never going to
make us give up free speech
she's right
some version of hate speech laws are
coming to the United States in fact
they're already here
we already have versions of hate speech
laws if you commit a crime if you rob a
guy and you take his wallet
and you say hey pal I'm going to take
your wallet you take it and you go away
then you'll be charged with robbery if
you go up to that same guy and you say
hey n-word hey
f-a-g-o-t hey whatever insert whatever
slur you want I'm gonna take your wallet
you will be charged with robbery and a
hate crime
and the only differentiating Factor the
only thing that would distinguish the
two robberies would be your speech
speech is increasingly criminalized
according to the standards of the ruling
liberal Elite what they consider to be
offensive furthermore as I wrote in my
book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds do I not have a bell
in my hotel room
want my bill
according to my book as I explained
pretty clearly there
there have always been
laws about speech in the United States
we still theoretically ban obscenity
we've had blasphemy laws on the books
this is true in every single Society so
when when the Davos Elites say you are
going to get some form of hate speech
laws we can either put our heads in the
sand and pretend that that's not true
and say la la la la I've got the First
Amendment which is going to protect me
for for saying anything that I want to
say which is not true now and has never
been true or we can actually engage with
the issue and say okay yeah we're gonna
have standards and Norms of speech it
can either be the insane backward Davos
liberal standards or we can assert our
own standards but we bury our heads in
the sand at our own risk because these
people even though they're trying to
downplay their power right now they have
a lot of power and they've got a lot of
power specifically in the United States
so the effective conservatives are the
ones who are pushing back specifically
on their agenda where are we seeing this
most clearly we're seeing it down in
Florida
we're seeing it with Governor Ron
DeSantis who has just announced that
Florida will join a number of other
Republican states in divesting from
asset managers that push an ESG agenda
environmental social governance policies
which basically just means radical
wokism
DeSantis said
that the approval of this resolution
will ensure the public fiduciary is
quote invest State funds in a manner
that prioritizes the highest return on
investment for Florida's taxpayers and
retirees without considering the
ideological agenda of the ESG movement
so what what DeSantis is saying here is
we're not going to buy into the world
economic Forum view of capitalism which
they call stakeholder capitalism
stakeholder capitalism says
it's not just shareholders but every
group in society is going to have some
say in how businesses are running
businesses are going to be accountable
not just to the shareholders but to the
locals and to the consumers and to the
suppliers and how exactly is this going
to work everything's a little a little
vague when it gets to the specifics
but they say shareholder capitalism is
not the way of the future
shareholder capitalism is the system
that we have right now it says that the
only duty of a company is to maximize
profits for shareholders and it has led
to a lot of material prosperity in the
last 50 years but it's only really been
about 50 years since shareholder
capitalism became the dominant form
of conducting business in the United
States the The Defenders of shareholder
capitalism the people you hear is the
the free market absolutists the
Disciples of Milton Friedman They are
going to try to tell you that
shareholder capitalism is some ancient
sacred idea it's not it has been useful
in many many ways but it isn't all that
old uh the the critics of stakeholder
capitalism the woke stuff that the world
economic forum is pushing they're going
to try to tell you that this is brand
new but it's not brand new actually
stakeholder capitalism the idea that
companies ought to be responsible to
more than just the shareholders of those
companies that's an idea that goes back
at least in 1932 it probably goes back a
little earlier than that though now
we're just using these terms to discuss
more complex ideas because the economy
is a complex thing and political
philosophy is a complex thing so what
are we going to do to to stop
stakeholder capitalism that the
left-wing version of it this is a fine
way to do it it's a fine way practically
to say we're going to divest from
BlackRock we're going to divest from
State Street we're going to divest from
Vanguard and how are we going to do it
we're going to repeat the same things
that Milton Friedman told us in the 70s
and the 80s that that's fine in the
short term but in the long term we are
going to have to deal with some of the
real criticism some of the legitimate
criticisms of the economic policies of
the last 50 years because the knock on
those policies is legit the knock is
that it exacerbates economic inequality
and it breaks down breaks down social
solidarity and you as a conservative
might not care all that much about
economic inequality it doesn't bother me
in principle but it does actually bother
me in practice because when economic
inequality becomes too drastic
people start getting a little antsy and
they start getting a little violent and
Society can break down and and this can
cause or at least be associated with a
breakdown in Social solidarity but but
the breakdown in Social solidarity
comes from a lot of other features of
the economy too an economic policy for
instance which we've had for the last 50
years that tells women that they should
get a job they should leave the home
they should delay having children they
should kill their babies if they do get
pregnant they should have multiple
partners and not settle down and not not
raise a family at an early age that kind
of capitalism and you're hearing that
message as much from the right-wing
capitalists as you are from the
left-wing feminists and radicals and and
free love type people that is going to
cause a breakdown in society and that's
a problem so I don't want to sound like
a Pinko over here okay I don't mean to
sound like I'm going to go dye my hair
or purple and you know start marching
with Greta thunberg or anything like
that but I think conservatives need to
be
completely unsentimental and and we need
to give credit where credit is due when
it comes to diagnoses of these problems
the libs I mean going back to Karl Marx
the lips are not bad at criticizing
certain aspects of society they don't
have good solutions for what to do about
it but that's what we need to do
and so the long-term solution here is
going to be okay if there are issues
with the economic policies from the
1970s let's address them and let's not
just dig up the graves of Milton
Friedman or Ronald Reagan they fought
their battles
they did good for their time I think
they did just fine now we have to fight
our battles too
and if the libs are going to be the only
people addressing these issues then the
libs are going to be the ones to
continue to wield political control
you know
the most celebrated interview show on
the internet many people are talking
about it listen everybody everybody I
talked to is talking about it has just
turned into
the greatest party game that would be
yes or no the game is backed by popular
demand it is a game
some might call harmful filled with hate
speech conspiracy content
and unsafe by Design but whatever you
want to call it it is available for
pre-order right now we ordered something
like a thousand copies of it just as a
little test run before Christmas sold
out immediately unfortunately we weren't
able to get more in before Christmas
we've just ordered a few thousand more
copies maybe even a little more than
that it is going to sell out again so
make sure you get your copy pre-ordered
today you know it's almost Bittersweet
that we sold out so quickly last time
but I think that we'd all stand to
benefit if a certain party going on in
Switzerland took some time to play okay
I really do wish we could have sent some
over there to Davos so head on over to
dailywire.com shop to pre-order yes or
no today
speaking of institutionalized wokeness
there's some basketball player you know
me I don't follow Sports very closely
baseball is the only one that I really
follow much at all but there's this
basketball player his name is proverov
and proverov has a religious objection
to putting on the Gay Pride flag on his
jersey and he was told by his team that
he had to wear a gay pride flag Jersey
and he said no I'm Christian that
actually contradicts my faith so no
thanks I'm not going to wear I'm not
going to wear the jersey and they said
you have to wear the Jersey he said I
want to wear the jersey and it was like
that scene in Seinfeld when during AIDS
everyone wanted you to wear a little
ribbon on your clothing and Kramer said
I want to wear the ribs wear the ribbon
why aren't you wearing the ribbon and it
has reached such a fever pitch that some
Looney Tune anchor just went on an
unhinged rant
about this man not wanting to wear a gay
symbol on his body
the theme is not hockey is for everyone
dot dot dot unless you don't believe in
gay rights then do whatever you want
if the National Hockey League's gonna do
this if any league is going to do this
do it properly
or reevaluate what you're doing
because there's not a lot of
repercussions and I'm seeing
from any League now it could change with
the NHL
could change with the NHL I think you
find the Flyers a million dollars for
this I'm not kidding figure this out and
stop offending people on nights where
it's not about that it's supposed to be
about inclusivity
the National Hockey League need to
attack this and figure this out
because what I heard last night was
offensive
and didn't make any sense because for
instance if that was a military night
okay right if anyone in Canada or in the
States on a military appreciation night
wouldn't wear a jersey pregame do you
have any idea the Uproar that would have
happened on that do you have any idea
the backlash do you have any idea what
happened on social media
it's it's ridiculous
do you have any idea I I'm uh I'm
laughing for a couple of reasons one is
I just proved my thesis that I don't
know anything about sports because I
thought it was a basketball player but
it's a hockey player okay all right
actually I prefer hockey to basketball
there's more fights it's a little bit
more exciting manly sport isn't it and
in this manly sport this Christian guy
says I don't want to wear the gay thing
please don't make me wear the gay thing
and then this Looney Tune on the NHL
channel he says could you imagine if if
a player didn't want to wear a jersey
honoring military veterans
foreign
as if to say that a man who goes out
there and fights for his country risks
his life to go kill the bad guys and
protect our freedom and our Traditions
that that is the same thing as a guy who
really really likes doing weird sex
stuff that both of those things are
equally deserving of our admiration well
Colonel I I really appreciate the
sacrifice you made being wounded
overseas to protect my country and you
Julio I'm glad that you went to the bath
house yesterday and that I find both of
those things so terribly honorable give
me both of your jerseys I'm gonna uh no
no one of those things is admirable one
of those things is at best kind of weird
and
a matter that we don't need to talk
about all that much publicly that's the
best case scenario okay how can you
imagine the guy he seems genuinely
confused and he goes on
nothing scares me more than any human
being who says I'm not doing this
because of my religious beliefs because
when you looked at people's lives you
normally say that publicly you throw up
at what you saw
you would throw up at what you saw
and I have seen that a million times in
a lot of different ways so don't don't
give me that with respect don't give me
that because no one's perfect all right
don't tell me don't don't feed me the
religious beliefs line and all of a
sudden the NHL is going to back off this
the National Hockey League today
needs to find that organization a
million dollars and reevaluate how they
support gay rights because because that
is insulting that is the number one
trending topic in Canada that is
insulting what happened in Philadelphia
you remember when the argument was hey
what's it matter to you
hey man what's your hang up why do you
care what people do in their bedrooms it
doesn't affect your life
but if you don't wear the gay t-shirt
we're gonna find you a million dollars
but it doesn't affect you
hey come on how does how does my gay
marriage affect your real marriage it
doesn't but give me a million dollars if
you ever so much as as even cast a
slight glance of aspersion on the
Glorious wonderful thing we call
homosexual sexual behavior
how dare you that would be like
insulting a military veteran
you see how that and do you remember at
the time
when the libs said all that the
conservatives said no man it's actually
a slippery slope and we're not all just
free-floating atoms so things that
affect anyone and certainly groups of
people end up affecting all of society
and they say shut up bigot shut up with
your stupid religion
and wear the T-shirt of My Religion get
your religion out of public where my
religion we're my flag we're my symbols
except my moral order my immoral order
frankly was what the left is pushing
and what he used one of the shallowest
arguments you'll ever hear he said I'm
sick and tired of people invoking their
religion especially these Christians
that's what he was insinuating he didn't
he's calling out a Christian in
particular but he said these religious
people generally do you know these CR
some of these Christians they could sin
did you know that they commit sins yeah
so you better not have any standard of
righter and wrong good and bad you
better not uh try to do good and avoid
evil because you're a fallen creature
and you sin so therefore you're a
hypocrite
having a standard and falling short of
that standard is not hypocrisy we use
the word hypocrisy today in a way that
is very very silly
having a standard and falling short of
that standard as you sincerely try to
uphold that standard is called being
human and pursuing virtue and it is
Central to the Christian Life it is the
the premise of Christianity that mankind
has fallen we can't save ourselves we
are in need of a savior we require God's
grace if we are to have salvation that's
it and this man this obvious religious
Billet bigot rather is is demonstrating
his ignorance and his intolerance and
his all the things that he accuses us of
so maybe the next time that there is a
cultural issue that comes up and those
crazy right-wing probably religious
fanatical types
try to draw draw a line in the sand and
say hey this is not good this is going
to affect society
maybe don't throw the nonsense back at
them and say oh how does this affect you
if politics affects all of us that's why
it's politics
that's what politics means politics
means public speaking of LGBT ism
I just read the most disturbing story
may be that I have ever read most
disturbing news story
I'm not going to read it I'm not going
to go too into detail at all because
this is just
horrifying it's by Mia cathell on Town
Hall I hope I'm not mispronouncing Mia's
last name
headline tapes we investigated a
Suburban LGBT pedophile ring here's what
we found
and it's a story of these two guys these
two gay guys who are in a gay marriage
and they adopted children two male
children they adopted the children from
a nominally Christian adoption agency
obviously a Christian adoption agency
that endorses same-sex marriage adoption
I it would be hard for me to understand
how that's a Christian adoption agency
but they do it and then the guys just
constantly raped the children and just
very young children now that the the
guys have been caught the children are
ages 9 and 11. they bragged about raping
the children they made you know all
sorts of videos and things they invited
their friends to do it that's if you
want to read the grizzly details it's
over a Town Hall you can give it a read
not for the faint of heart so I don't
necessarily recommend you do it
obviously these men if they are guilty
of what what they are accused of doing
obviously they should be executed
there's no question about that as far as
I'm concerned even if you are a little
worried about the death penalty and even
if you have objections to the death
penalty which I do not I think the death
penalty is perfectly just and legitimate
and Christian and acceptable but even if
you do uh one
I I think irrefutable
uh argument for the death penalty Beyond
mere retribution
which I think is ultimately the point of
all criminal justice but but beyond that
you could you you would have to say that
for the purposes of protecting the
public from the further predations of
these animals these absolute criminals
uh the death penalty would be justified
at the very least to protect people if
not purely for the purpose of justice
and retribution at least to protect
people and you know with the way that
our justice system works now if these
pedos go to prison well if there were
Justice in the prison system they would
not last very long in prison but if they
did if they did make it you know they'd
be let out you know they'd be let out we
don't we don't keep criminals in jail in
this country not these days
they probably would be let out and what
would they do they'd do it again
so sure we I think most most reasonable
people agree these two men should be
executed very swiftly for what they did
but when will we address the broader
issues
are we going to address the broader
issue are we willing to end the Absurd
and barbaric practice of same-sex and
single parent adoption
and certainly when it comes to single
parent adoption certainly single male
parent adoption
I think single parent adoption generally
should be
discouraged if not just made illegal
outright certainly same-sex adoption
should be illegal a child has a right to
his natural mother and father to it to
to be conceived within the context of a
marriage and in the conjugal Act of his
parents
we know that there are something like 36
couples trying to adopt every newborn
baby put up production in the United
States there's no shortage of mommies
and daddies married to one another who
want to adopt babies okay there's no
shortage of that at all and yet because
of wokeness and political correctness
we've got to say no well we shouldn't
discriminate against gay men or single
parents who want to adopt but of course
we should because it's not about the
adults
whether they want to satisfy the most
horrific lusts they could have or
whether they just want a kid and they
didn't get married and they just want to
have a kid
we we know that it is better for a child
to be raised in a marriage in a real
marriage with a mother and a father and
so at the very least for newborn babies
where the situation is really really
straightforward
we should prioritize the children over
the parents no question about that we're
not allowed to say that that's not
politically correct we're not allowed to
point out that
child sex abuse is much more prevalent
among LGBT identified people I'm not
saying all gay guys are child abusers
obviously that is not the case the vast
majority of gay guys are not child
abusers but the numbers are the numbers
the LGBT identification in the United
States is 7.1 percent Accord that's
according to Gallup according to the
Williams Institute at UCLA law so not
some far-right Think Tank according to a
very liberal storied institution 20 of
registered sex offenders identify as
LGBT we're not allowed to say that we're
not allowed to confront that fact
because it's Politically Incorrect so
what happens these stories pop up and
you don't read about it anywhere you
read about it in town hall maybe you
hear it on my show and that's it and it
gets buried
for what so that we can continue
perpetuating lies that harm all of
society that harms certain people
specifically but harm all of us when we
are forced to live in a culture of Lies
We should say no to that
this month we are celebrating the
anniversary of one of the greatest
moments in Daily wire history when we
said no to Joe Biden
after months of leading the legal battle
against the federal government in a
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court ruled in our favor blocked
the Biden administration's outrageous
vaccine mandate
see that was a Freudian slip I almost
said the Obama it's kind of like the
obiden administration it's just the it's
just the third term
for Barack Obama this mandate would have
said a dangerous precedent giving the
unelected OSHA power over the personal
medical decisions of American citizens
the Supreme Court recognized this gross
power grab obviously made the right
decision
we are so proud to have led the charge
in this fight we could not have done it
without you thousands of you joined the
daily wire over a million Americans
signed our petition against the mandates
to celebrate we are offering 40 percent
off our annual memberships with the code
do not comply
like life would have been really tough
had that mandate gone into effect not
just for us at the daily wire but for
everybody out there who works for a
private business so celebrate one of the
Great Moments in Daily wire history with
40 off on your annual membership join
out dailywire.com subscribe join the
winning team as we continue to crush the
libs
do not comply use that code for 40 off
speaking of political dishonesty the
White House has still not managed to
come up with a coherent and uniform line
to answer for Joe Biden's mishandling of
classified documents
mishandling of documents when he had no
right to do it unlike Trump Joe Biden
was not the president
when he was allegedly mishandling these
documents unlike Trump they weren't just
locked in a closet where the National
Archives knew where they were they were
in his garage they were in in a garage
that Hunter had access to and used
Hunter Biden while he was Shilling his
influence for the ukrainians and the
Chinese highly sensitive classified
documents in their garage
classified documents in Joe Biden's fake
Think Tank which was funded by the
Chinese Communists you think the donors
maybe took a walk through the office
maybe had some access to those documents
entirely plausible
no
no they haven't come up with an answer
to it in fact green Jean-Pierre is
pretty much just walking out because she
can't answer
that turned out to be false are you
sorry about that I'll see you tomorrow
come talk to me I'll see you tomorrow
there she is and the reporter you heard
the first part was a little bit cut off
by the microphones was James Rosen who's
a very serious journalist he's worked
for
slightly more right-wing Outlets he
worked for Fox News uh for a while but
James Rosen is considered a very very
mainstream journalist he pointed out at
least six times that kjp had claimed
that all Biden classified documents were
accounted for and that turned out to be
false so she either was completely
ignorant or she was lying and so he said
hey you can't lie to us I know that your
job is to spin but you can't really lie
are you going to apologize he says bye
see you're not even going to acknowledge
it but we know this because Joe Biden is
even by politician standards the most
notorious liar in our political life
today more than Trump I'm not saying
Trump has never said anything that isn't
totally true but Biden has said many
more significant serious lies for longer
Barack Obama has told very very serious
lies if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor oh Biden's Biden still
got him beat Hillary
bill
well I did not have sexual relate Biden
still got him beat and now we just found
out proof that the Biden lied again
Biden claimed
just a few days ago I talked about it on
the show that he grew up in a black
Protestant Church which is was a little
strange when he said it because Biden
constantly brags about how he's a devout
Catholic even though he doesn't believe
undeniable truths required dogmas of the
Catholic Church Joe Biden
nevertheless presents himself as a
devout Catholic so how could a devout
Catholic every day after Mass go Worship
in a black
well it doesn't matter if it's a black
church it pro he called it a black
church because he also is offensively
denying that there are black Catholics
of which there are many but but to go to
a Protestant church that itself would be
considered a sin in in the Catholic
church and no one believed it anyway
though do you seriously believe that
Corn Pop took Joe to the black church
after no of course not and now we have
proof of it because Joe Biden was at
Rafael warnock's church and there were
some real spiritual hymns going on
people were moving they were flowing
they were clapping
Joe Biden couldn't move
there he is you see all the choir in the
background singing about the spirit and
Biden doesn't know what to do
even Warnock he's clapping
[Music]
everybody out there in the congregation
was Biden who raises his hand
uh
hmm
what do I do
that is not a man
who has ever
seriously attended a black Protestant
Church you gotta move he reminds like
the opening scene of the jerk with Steve
Martin I was born a poor black child and
then he's he's there and the way that he
finds out he's adopted is because he
can't he can't dance because he doesn't
have any rhythm certainly Joe Biden uh
too now speaking of contrasting
leadership
as the world economic Forum 2023 wraps
up this this is an important year for
the world economic Forum because it
marks the first year in my life that
there has been widespread attention to
this globalist Meetup in the middle of
the Swiss Alps in a very very rarefied
territory that's very expensive to get
to
and the reason it's held there is
because it's hard to get to and they're
you're not going to have a lot of
protesters making it all the way up the
mountain in the Swiss Alps and now a lot
of people are paying attention to it
don't forget though
Donald Trump showed up to the world
economic Forum back in 2018.
but unlike the squish Republicans who
have gone
Donald Trump showed up to the world
economic forum
with a clear message for the globalist
Liberals
I'm aware that you're strong leadership
is open to misconceptions and biased
interpretations
Circle
it is so essential for us since Rome
to listen directly to you I'm here today
to represent the interests of the
American people the world is witnessing
the Resurgence of a strong and
prosperous America
I'm here to deliver a simple message
there has never been a better time to
hire to build to invest and to grow in
the United States
regulation is stealth taxation
the U.S like many other countries
unelected bureaucrats I mean we have
believe me we have them all over the
place and they've imposed crushing and
anti-business and anti-worker
regulations on our citizens with no vote
no legislative debate and no real
accountability
in America those days are over
he showed up to the world economic Forum
to tell these people that he disagreed
with everything that they held dear
that's a beautiful thing
and it shows you a good way forward
because the Republicans who showed up to
this thing got Flack rightly so because
the Republicans who showed up to this
thing broadly seem on board with the
world economic Forum great reset type
agenda
but
the reason they were criticized for that
is because we had these people's numbers
before they showed up to Davos
if if Donald Trump showed up to Davos I
think we know he's not going there to
Kiss the Ring of Klaus Schwab if Lauren
bobert showed up to Davos to give a
speech if she were ever invited I sort
of doubt that someone that right wing
would be invited but if she were
we would know that she's going there to
stick a finger in the eye the question
we've got to ask about this is
is not are you willing to engage in this
culture I think it'd be great I want I
want Trump to show up every year I want
him to just stick a finger in their eye
every single year I think that would be
wonderful I'm not saying we totally
disengage from the libs
frankly I think that kind of attitude is
what's got us in this mess in the first
place we abandon the universities we
abandoned Hollywood we abandon the
political realm because we we convinced
ourselves that wielding political power
was wrong per se and what did that do
that just gave the libs the stage no
don't give them the stage show up and
tell them what you think and bring them
into line that's fine by me you just got
to know where they stand and who they
stand for Gretchen Whitmer the governor
of Michigan Democrat Governor of
Michigan was was at the world economic
Forum today
why was she here was she here to
represent the interests of the American
people was she here to represent her
constituents no of course not
she was here to play along with the
bidding of the Davos set
who know who the people are standing for
if you can read clearly what they stand
for
then send them out send them out to
engage in the world there's nothing
wrong with that we just have to win
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the voicemail bag brought to you by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com right now
select a plan enter code Knowles kwles
to get 50 off your first month
take it away with the first question hey
Michael in today's world is it possible
to separate someone from being
conservative and being a republican with
the number of Squish Republicans growing
when is it time the true conservatives
cut ties and create party that actually
stands on true conservative Foundation
and will actually stand by that
thanks
we will never Purge the squishes from
the Republican party that is not
possible because there are not enough
hardcore conservatives and there are
many many squishes and there are many
many libs
so you you do have to figure out a way
to get the squishes to work with you and
to vote for your sorts of candidates the
problem is not that there are squishes
who vote for Republican candidates the
problem is that the Republican
politicians cater to the squishes over
the conservatives and so what we have to
do
is figure out a way for the
conservatives not to leave the alliance
that we've made with the squishes not to
but but to lead the alliance that we've
made with the squishes
we need to craft the political
conditions and this is an art politics
is an art
such that
the liberal the the squishes rather will
go along with what the conservatives we
conservatives want them to go along with
and that the squishes will not be
tempted to defect for the Liberals
and that's just that requires a little
bit of massage it's it's why you you've
you've got to
be wise as a dove and innocent as a
serpent and and you you can't actually
affect political progress and change and
all the buzzwords that we want to affect
you can't you can't do good in the
political realm if you are uh going to
let the perfect get in the way of the
good we've just got to figure out a way
to be a little gutsier because as long
as the conservatives Remain the junior
partner in this Alliance that we've made
with the squishes then we might as well
vote for Democrats half the time okay
next question
hey Michael uh this is Jake I've noticed
there's a trend that seems to be uh
maligning Millennials for not growing up
and I think that the uh the Boomers who
uh are my parents as a millennial uh
don't receive this criticism when they
absolutely should I don't think that
they have ever got out of a
materialistic hedonistic mindset they
had since they were children and I think
that extrapolates into the fact that
they run from being Patriarchs and
matriarchs of a family and they cut bait
leave their abandon their children and
their grandchildren for retirement homes
in Florida and hoarding wealth they have
65 percent of the wealth in the country
they had 20 percent when they were my
age and my generation Millennials have
four percent of the wealth so so I don't
think that that we should stop at
criticizing Millennials for not growing
up fair enough very good point and yes
as a matter of fact the Boomers deserve
all the criticism that they get as a
generation however
Millennials and I guess some of the
older Zoomers should not be the ones to
criticize them
the reason for that is they are our
parents and that's and that's wrong you
have to honor your father and mother I'm
not saying that the criticism of the
Boomers
is not warranted I was talking to Drew
my very good friend who happens to be a
boomer he said Michael we ruined
everything it was all the Boomer's fault
everything they say about us is true and
I know we know that
and yet it is still wrong for
Millennials as a rule to to whine about
the Boomers because there are parents
and we should say thank you thank you
Boomers Boomer parents for giving us the
things you gave us thank you for doing
your best we appreciate the gift of life
you gave us we're going to honor our
mothers and fathers we can learn from
the Boomers and not make some of the
mistakes that they did
hey Michael huge fan of the show I
wanted to ask you a question related to
the medical world and what your opinion
is on it so in Star Trek Voyager there's
an episode where a patient who is dying
on the medical bed was offered treatment
to save him however the Doctor Who was
performing the operation was a doctor
who performed research on the patient
species of people and almost entirely
killed them all from these experiments
obviously the patient refused treatment
on the grounds that he didn't want
research performed on him that was done
on his people involuntarily so what
would you do in this situation I think I
know your answer but I'd love to hear it
thanks
well I'm I'm glad that you know my
answer I'm not sure that I know my
answer
so I'd like you to inform me of my
answer because I would just need to know
much more
I would I would need to know
if the
mengala type of doctor had had a change
of heart had he repented he had he
regretted what he had done
and then gone ahead and changed his ways
and could I trust that he was going to
give me decent medical care if I could
trust that then I wouldn't I wouldn't
refuse the life-saving medical care just
because of some sins he had committed in
the past I wouldn't cut off my nose
despite my face that would be crazy now
if I thought that he was just going to
experiment on me and rip my guts out and
do all sorts of experiments on them then
I'd say no I probably would refuse the
care because it wouldn't be care it
would be just further abuse but I do
think it also depends do I have a
terminal illness do I have a kind of a
disease that would require extraordinary
Extraordinary Measures to keep me alive
and what I would I be very very aged and
frail at this point would I be nearing
natural death anyway uh would would with
the care be ordinary kind of medical
care or extraordinary kind of medical
care what
what would it be I'd have to because if
it were ordinary Medical Care and it
were a normal course of events I think I
would probably have an obligation to
accept it
because because of the law of
self-preservation which is part of the
natural law so I don't know and I've
never seen Star Trek so I really don't
know next question
hi Michael my name is RJ longtime
listener I was with my friends when the
issue of whether or not God exists came
up I said he did and they agreed
somewhat but they said there was no way
to be sure
I gave what was essentially C.S Lewis's
argument for the Tau that you know that
there is such a thing as an objective of
good and bad and there's universal truth
within all of us
they rejected this and said there is no
Universal morality and they use slavery
as an example not the fact that it
existed and still exists but there were
many who genuinely did not believe they
were doing anything wrong
I've struggled with this as the Taoist
C.S Lewis describes it would mean that
no one or at least the vast majority of
people could participate in something
such as slavery without seeing it as
objectively evil the argument for a
universal truth and against moral moral
relativism is what brought me back to
Christianity after several years of
winning belief please clear this seeming
contradiction as it would vastly improve
my state of mind the daily wire and of
course C.S Lewis have been instrumental
in guiding my faith and though you've
yet to converted me to Catholicism give
him more time I have no doubt he'll get
me there
thanks Michael I greatly appreciate it
I'm very pleased to hear all of that
that's absolutely wonderful so wow
that's that's all really great well
since you're you're basically begging me
to to convert you to Catholicism I I
would quote the first Vatican Council
not the second Vatican Council but the
first Vatican Council which
states that the existence of God can be
known with certainty by the light of
human reason from the natural world okay
so I I know that today many modern
people want to say well we can never
really know if God exists or not and
it's just a pure leap of faith man and
we don't but that that is not true we
can know for certain that God exists
there are many good arguments as to why
God exists you name one of those
arguments which is that we know that
some things are better than other things
we know uh that there are objective
realities there's objective goodness if
anything is better than any other thing
then there has to be a maximally great
thing the sumo bonum to use I don't know
some kind is that Spanish or something I
don't know that's some kind of old
language if if uh anything is true or
false then there has to be an objective
reality that under underlies the whole
world if things are in motion we know
that in our universe things are in
motion then there has to be some way
that they got to be in motion
if things are caused in this world and
if we see the effects of those causes
then there has to be a first cause there
has to be an uncaused cause there are
many other arguments you can go through
the five Arguments for the existence of
God of Saint Thomas Aquinas
there are many other good arguments I
love the ontological argument for God
that's not the most popular one the fact
that God is by definition the maximally
great being and it's better to exist
than not to exist therefore God by
definition must exist it's a Charming
argument doesn't convince a lot of
people
so I think it did convince C.S Lewis so
anyway those are all good arguments and
so if your friend's objection is that
some people disagree over certain
aspects of morality I don't deny that
but I don't think that undermines
Lewis's understanding of the Tau either
that that doesn't undermine the fact
that human beings are born with a moral
conscience and we can know that certain
things are right and wrong simply by
reason because they're a part of the
natural law that doesn't undermine that
it isn't it is in fact the case that one
certain people are just so eccentric or
so depraved that they're that their
reason and conscience is defective uh
that happens in the world you know this
is a fallen world and so uh we need
education to fix those those rare
occasions uh it's also the case that uh
certain instantiations of moral laws can
look different in different places
so we recognize that it is wrong to
commit murder but different
jurisdictions will have different laws
on killing killing by the state killing
as a matter of Retribution killing in
times of war and so you can see
different instantiations of that and
reasonable Minds can disagree over those
things but that wouldn't contradict the
natural law much more to say on this
topic but we're running out of time and
I want to get to at least one mailbag
question okay this mailbag question is
from John it is on
the topic of pornography okay and we
don't have a mailbag segment or a rather
a member block segment today because I'm
on the road so I'm just going to go
along and I'm going to do it anyway
because I want to at least get to one
written mailbag and this is one people
send in porn questions all the time
hello Michael many young single guys
like me have struggles with porn I would
also like to get married and have a
family someday but I feel like my
addiction is an obstacle to that I don't
feel like it's a very fair to subject a
future wife to my problem as I know how
painful it is for women whose husbands
watch porn what do you think is the best
approach you often make the point that
it's a Fallen World which is true but
should my fallenness discourage me from
getting married thanks John no it
shouldn't discourage you from getting
married it should encourage you to
practice virtue and to repent of your
sins and to and to do so realistically
okay you you point out here and I
pointed out on the show all the time
guys write into me constantly about porn
I talk to priests priests tell me that
90 plus of the guys who show up into the
confessional are confessing looking at
porn at some point it's ubiquitous it's
everywhere okay and it's not entirely
your fault you live in a culture that
promotes porn where we've all got these
little portals to hell in our pockets
and we've got computers everywhere and
even just ordinary Billboards and TV
shows have a lot of pornographic content
so go easy on yourself
but don't but don't relax your view of
morality because your moral intuition is
right and you're recognizing that it's
destroying your life so so treat it like
any other addiction you call it an
addiction treat it like any other
addiction
and just just try to go one day without
looking at it if you're looking at porn
every single day just try to go one day
without looking at porn this is what
you'd tell an alcoholic some guys
drinking all the time every single day
say try to go one day without a drink
try to go one day without looking
important you're not saying I'm gonna go
my whole life and you're you're gonna
get the shakes like you're a drug addict
just so you're gonna go one day if
you're looking at porn I don't know
let's say you're looking at porn
three times a week
say okay I'm gonna try not to look at
porn at all but if I do I'm only going
to look at it one time a week and then
you do that for a little bit and maybe
you backslide people backslide but but
then after a while say okay maybe I'm if
you if you reduced it to two times a
week reduce it to one time if you reduce
it to one time reduce it to no times
you can grow in these things the the
devil's trick is to convince you that
you can never improve because he's going
to to make you a slave to your lusts but
habits are such that because
because virtue is a habit the more you
practice virtue the easier it's going to
be Vice is a habit and so the more you
you engage in a vice the harder it's
going to be to pull away from that bison
so time is is your friend here okay and
if you just keep it up day by day at a
time and I would recommend uh
sacramental confession I know that some
people don't buy into sacramental
confession I think it spiritually is
very effective and even if you don't buy
that psychologically It's very effective
to get on your knees and confess your
sins to God in the presence of a man who
you believe has the power to forgive
sins and cleanse your soul
and I I happen to believe that those
Graces actually work they they have a
real effect on your soul uh but
psychologically at least even if you're
a hardcore atheist
you I think you can understand why that
would work and why that kind of
accountability would work and why that
reassurance that okay son your sins are
forgiven it's a Fallen World don't worry
don't let your sins bury you don't let
your bad habits bear you you can improve
so take it seriously uh but but do so in
the light of Grace that's uh that's the
only way that you're going to overcome
it and I think you can overcome it all
right that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael null show
see you next time foreign
[Music]